Fox Sports NFL Sunday also Bellator MMA
broadcaster and analysis but what I know
so well for is the founder of emerging
vets and players MVP good friend of mine
good friend of the show welcome Jay good
morning good morning how you doing
brother I'm doing great man this is this
is a lot of fun thanks for thanks for
coming on this journey with me
a lot of people don't know but you and I
you know we knew each other of course
when I played you worked a lot for CBS
when I was down in Tampa and you you
learned a few things about me and and my
teammates with John with uh with Lynch
and with Ronde and all those guys but we
we went our separate ways right you
moved up the ladder I fell to the bottom
of the earth and about two and a half
years ago Nate Boyer brought me into a
little program you started and what what
has transpired since that moment I mean
really Jim the best part is Nate brings
brings you in he goes hey man I'm
bringing Ryan Leaf and I go Ryan Leaf
don't bring that bbbbb pin here and Nate
being the great human being that he is
goes hey Jay you don't decide who we
helped freaking Nate why do you gotta be
such a good person and for the people
out there don't know it was amazing we
had a veteran in there who was going
over and he was homeless and he was
talking I met this girl and had no value
and ma'am Ryan raised his hand from the
back of the room instead of you guys
talking about value of money just you
guys know my name is Ryan Lee from you
know I had everything and all the money
in the world I could possibly want and
you know I ended up you know after my
career ended and would you say Ryan and
said I yeah ed what a mansion in San
Diego you know multi-million dollar
contract and still even with that you
try to kill yourself
so money doesn't solve everything and
then you were making with a 15 bucks an
hour driving people to and from reality
yeah tell us it's the happiest I've ever
been and I'm like oh my god this dude
could save millions of lives if we
bottle this up man and get it out there
and certainly that's what's happened
dude I'm very proud in I know it's a
daily battle for you and anybody else
but it's you know nothing's done
perfectly if in fact you keep doing
it more and more and more that's the
journey is though is the success it's
not you don't suddenly finally get
somewhere and that's it it's this
journey of ups and downs that that's a
success and you know you've I think God
every day in my life and you walked in
that gym because you became a vehicle
for us also to help save lives and I I
think that's gonna be my legacy that's
why God put me here I'm on the earth to
try and use my big mouth to save the
lives of our veterans a lot of players
and athletes have you know been around
for so many years in the NFL and have
somebody like you come in there and help
this journey with me I'm forever
grateful what's been the biggest
takeaway in transformation seeing these
vets and former players come together
why is it so why does it work so well I
think they look up to each other and
they look it's badasses empowering other
badasses you know it's and football
players and you know they've always
looked up to combat vets and you know
athlete took up to combat vets and
combat vets look up to pro athletes when
they're out there in battle and these
guys are out there days on end they look
forward to getting back to base and
watching football game or watching a
fight or watching a game it's just yeah
the commonality between the two it just
made so much sense to put these two
together and have them coach each other
up and Ron you've been in the room this
is the smartest group of people you
already around in your life we every
Wednesday night we meet unbreakable my
Jim up in Hollywood for the LA chapter
it's the only group I could talk about
suicide talk about depression could talk
about guys getting blown up shot at shot
down and laughs two minutes later and
the it really is incredible how much how
much tolerance this room has they'd even
say they said hey we may not agree with
everything that everybody says or
doesn't hear but we fought for your
right to do something we don't agree
with even that alone it's so much it's
so much better of a statement than
anything I could ever come up with it is
it's been transformational in my life I
know it's been transformational in yours
or listen to Jay Glazer from from Fox
NFL Sunday NFL insider I wanted to talk
a little bit about of course the the big
prognostication you made a couple months
ago about old Dale Beckham jr. of course
possibly being on the trade block you've
got a lot of feedback for that and then
late last Worley last week yeah late
last week it goes down gentlemen sends
him over Cleveland now reunited with
Jarvis Landry and now with second-year
quarterback Baker Phelan Mayfield talk
to us about how that all transpired and
played out look what I said it you know
I made it was a prediction but it was
something I knew was gonna happen
that you know I was really kind of
surprised what the reaction was because
you know I started in New York people
knew I've had a lot of giant stories
I've been very worried in there since
1993 so the reaction back like it wasn't
gonna happen I didn't know what I was
talking about kind of taken aback oh
they hate you you're my people but then
they were really started firing off in
the way only New Yorkers can so I fired
off in a very New Yorkers way as well
and but it was you know interesting it's
like a couple of years ago you know I
said I'm Fox NFL Sunday that Jim
Harbaugh would not be back as head coach
the 49ers no matter what even if they
want a Super Bowl that year and I got
killed for that but it ended up
happening and this was this reaction was
probably ten times more violent and more
vitriol than that one and it's like hey
I'm just telling you what's gonna happen
that's what you guys pay me for you guys
is the fans you guys pay me for it and
you know if I say something I want to
make sure I'd rather be right 100
percent of time and never first on a
story and first on a bunch of them and
be wrong 5% of the time I want people
know if I say something
I'm Sox interval Sunday or anywhere else
you could take it to the back and you
know I have a responsibility to even the
other guys on the show that that's a
love like you know I compete at or
perform at so I was kind of I was taken
aback by it but it's also Ryan it was
information and I have and I who was
going on and yeah you know I know David
gentleman's come out also today
and talked and said well this is just
something that came about with the brows
that's true came about a late with the
Browns but this was just uh sometimes a
relationship just fizzles out this
offseason has been already fireworks
galore right
Le'Veon Bell is gone Antonio Brown is
gone yet they're still rumblings out of
Pittsburgh that the real issue may have
truly been and we saw with the Kolbert
quote about having 52 kids in the locker
room it may ultimately be Big Ben our
franchise quarterbacks do they have too
much power in those locker rooms that it
could decimate an entire franchise one
even like the Pittsburgh Steelers that
has been dominant for years and years
and years decimated because they've
they've been dominant for so long it may
be coming to a head right now right and
again some kind of relationships just
you know it's just time and yet big you
know Ben definitely has a lot of juice
in there I wouldn't come out and said
that he has that much juice cuz
alienates everybody else I really get
that but yeah we know the quarterbacks
have an awful lot of power and they end
up spending more time with their head
coach if there's an offensive coach and
that's you know that's your feel general
if we want to go with you know a
military term when when you have an
offseason like this sometimes the quiet
ones are making the biggest advances
right where is it been quiet this
offseason for players that need to make
a big jump into this year and what are
you expecting from people like that say
Sam darn 'old who've just picked up
leaving on bail others that are having a
really quiet offseason like it should be
not a lot of news and we're gonna see
them when camp opens up in late July you
know it's just the way there's all
seasons gone it's going this way because
you know it's a copycat league for two
years ago the Eagles win the Super Bowl
identified bringing in a bunch of guys
and trading for their joys and you know
sign a LeSean and you know that you know
building the office of why they did that
they kind of they wheeled and dealed and
then last year the Rams get an awful lot
of wheeling and dealing so I mean people
looking to go oh that's that's and
that's the norm for right now the league
is cyclical and will go
back down because you know I like what
the goats are done they owe us money and
they're like we're just not going to
spending during the insanity phase
there's always an insanity phase of free
agency always happens but if you sit
tight and also you can start getting
these really great deals like no Bears
did with haha
and you know there's a couple other you
know there'll be a couple other studs
that kind of dropped out here you can
kind of get to these lower lower deals
now now those things calm down but you
know it's the insanity of that first
wave is there's always a huge divide
between those who end up spending and
those who say let's just wait it out
we're listening to Jay Glazer NFL
insider Fox NFL Sunday more importantly
founder of MVP emerging vets and players
you can go to www.hsn
our sword to check it out let's get you
out of here with this one the big story
of course in the offseason I think
before the obj trade was Antonio Brown
where is he gonna go what are the
Oakland Raiders doing is it something
that is going to be impactful enough
this year to be you know competitive in
the AFC West or is this still going to
be a work in progress for a couple more
years under Jon Gruden isola maybe to
help their defense right the deep-ass
workers they need help that defense
route you know having a guy like Eddie
certainly helps you know it's
interesting people are going to why a B
only go for 3 and a 5 in Odell went for
a 1-2-3 and peppers the difference is
that the Steelers they showed their hand
there is no poker or like we just
addition by subtraction we want to get
rid of where the Giants were able to
hold their cards much closer to the vest
and act like alone we're not going to do
it we're not desperate to get rid of you
know if something comes along we'll do
it even though I know that you know
their intention was straight them there
was a disparate if they played it
differently maybe is still one of most
dynamic playmakers
in the NFL but the Raiders an awful lot
of holes that they need to fill over
there but I think the key is how do they
use these graphics they use these
graphics well and they hit on them then
yeah the Raiders are building the right
way if they don't and you know get rid
of khalil macton still they make a lot
of sense are they is are they they saw
it on his derrick karr going to be the
guy moving forward in Oakland or is
there still a chance that he's not what
Jon Gruden necessarily wants in his kind
of offense and there could be a
quarterback change still before the
start of the season never I'm not gonna
predict anything later Dukas everytime
you think that we do one thing they do
another they just you know even when I
said I wasn't want to broke the story
about them looking at trade Amari Cooper
and they said no not happening
he was trading a few days later a week
later you know even with how the whole
Khalil max thing went down they kind of
go back and forth back over I do think
they have a grown up in the room now and
Mike Mac I think that's great they got a
grown up in that room that it's gonna
help that team well thanks Jay Jay
Glazer from NFL Fox NFL Sunday as well
as NFL insider I just wanted you know of
course say to you you you're you're a
huge factor and the fact that I'm
actually sitting up here hosting the
show today I am so grateful that you got
to be on the show today to share this
with me so I appreciate you brother keep
doing what you're doing I love the I
love it I'd rather be late and right
every single time then then first and
wrong you know a portion the time keep
it up
we'll look forward to hearing from you
soon thank you brother appreciate it man
I Love You Man remember I hope you took
my advice and you wore pants in studio
today are you wearing pants I didn't I
didn't I thought that would help I
thought that would help
I'm still learning I'm still learning
about this broadcasting business blazer
everybody Fox NFL Sunday mentor of mine
he's awesome it's always great he's
helped me a ton the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience